[Música]
el pequeño país insular de slam acá
estaba viviendo momentos convulsos y una
crisis social y de gobierno aguda miles
de personas han salido a las calles en
las últimas semanas para protestar por
la grave situación económica de la que
culpan al gobierno esta situación que
llegó hasta tal punto que el presidente
rajapaksa huyó del país días después de
que un grupo de manifestantes asaltar la
residencia presidencial tras la huida el
primer ministro running with me singer
fue nombrado presidente interino
declarado también y declaró entonces el
estado emergencia en todo el país pero
ahora la ciudadanía exige su renuncia
como se llegó hasta aquí se lo
preguntamos entonces a nuestra primera
mitad del día y es la doctora son la
ansia márquez analista internacional
comunista del periódico el universal de
méxico son lanchas gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
porque digamos de esta nación en el
océano índico poblada en su mayoría por
tres grupos étnicos distintos llegó a
tal punto inestabilidad como se generó
esta aguda crisis en sí la ncaa
pues mira hay muchos factores buenos
días y muchísimas gracias por la
invitación hay varios factores que han
influido en que se diera este esta
crisis económica en la que están ahorita
económica y política en la que están
ahorita envueltos
y yo por lo menos
intuyo o analizó que hay dos vertientes
distintas una interna y otra externa los
factores internos tienen mucho que ver
con las decisiones de política económica
que ha tomado que tomó el gobierno en
los últimos en los últimos tres años
especialmente durante la pandemia y uno
de ellos tiene que ver con el cierre con
los no downs que afectaron muy
significativamente el turismo que es uno
de los sectores económicos más
importantes del país y el segundo tiene
que ver con una nueva política impulsada
por el gobierno para evitar el uso de
fertilizantes químicos
en la isla y esto bueno pues yo dio paso
a una crisis muy grave en términos de la
agricultura sir lanka había sido durante
toda su historia
un país que había sido autónomo pues
había generado sus propios su propia
autoconsumo por lo menos para él para el
arroz y había sido suficiente por lo
menos para exportación y de pronto viene
esta política para
prohibir la importación de agroquímicos
pensando en una historia o en una idea
más de fomentar el uso de algo más verde
de una de una agricultura mucho más
verde y bueno pues esto afectó a
millones de agricultores que perdieron
básicamente todo y se quedaron sin
cultivos y bueno esto incremento el
problema no entonces ahí tenemos varios
factores hubo recortes también en
impuestos internamente que también
afectaron los ingresos del estado y por
el otro lado a nivel externo pues
tenemos lo que ya estamos ya sabemos que
existe a nivel global toda la guerra con
ucrania
que ha generado obviamente una subida de
precios de combustibles que van
afectados y muy muy gravemente a hacer
la ncaa y también el problema que se
tiene también con la crisis y el
desabasto de alimentos entonces son
estos 2
factores tanto internos como externos
que han generado la crisis que están
viviendo actualmente claro su lancia
esto digamos que también se incluye el
manejo de gobierno el mal manejo de
gobierno digamos ante esta también
crisis que por lo que estás diciendo
pues se podía digamos pensar que podría
llegar ese blanca a un escenario como el
que estamos viviendo actualmente porque
el ejecutivo digamos de él el presidente
que dimitió votaba se contaba ya raya
pacsa y no no pues tomó políticas
necesarias para no llegar a este punto
de no retorno que lo obligó a oír del
país
y no las tomo me parece que por vaya por
una intención de permanecer en el poder
mucho más mucho más tiempo y creo
también que fue una cuestión de
ineptitud honestamente me parece que fue
una cuestión de ineptitud el problema
interno de la agricultura empezó a
generar conflictos desde el año pasado
esto ni siquiera es nuevo desde el año
pasado ya se tenían problemas de
desabasto alimentario ya había una
crisis muy fuerte agroalimentaria y no
se tomaron las decisiones correctas en
los momentos correctos cuando se quiso
echar hacia atrás la política de
prohibición de importación de
fertilizantes agroquímicos
ya fuego demasiado tarde no hubo
suficientes para que los agricultores
pudieran aprovecharlos en ese momento y
pudieran realmente tener en los tiempos
necesarios las cosechas que hubieran que
se hubieran deseado entonces se tomaron
decisiones a destiempo y bueno ya ya fue
absolutamente insuficiente y en términos
por ejemplo de la importación del gas
del gas del petróleo y de los
combustibles
lo que sucedió es que el país empezó a
tener una escalada de precios muy grande
la escala sumada a la escalada de
precios internacional lo que ocasionó es
que cuando ellos quisieron comprar e
importar
y
combustibles lo que sucedió es que lo
que antes les alcanzaba para comprar
tres meses que les alcanzaría para tres
meses ahora solamente les estaba
alcanzando para un mes entonces pues
obviamente fue insuficiente cuando
cuando se dieron cuenta realmente ya no
había vuelta atrás ya la gente estaba
muy enojada ya no había medicamentos ya
no había alimentos ya no había
combustible en las escuelas tuvieron que
cerrar y bueno pues fue fue un conjunto
de malas decisiones todas encadenadas y
cuando quisieron echarlo para atrás pues
ya no había ya no fue suficiente